Nous sommes en 1780.
Kraus, un ami de Kant, se rend à une réception
en plein air.
Beaucoup de profs de l’université de Königsberg
sont présents.
Dans la conversation, ils se demandent quelle
est la philosophie qui domine actuellement.
Kraus dit que Kant a sur son bureau un manuscrit
— celui de la Critique de la raison pure
— qui va faire suer les philosophes.
Là, les profs rigolent.
Kant est un touriste !
Si une révolution doit se produire en philosophie,
ce n’est certainement pas lui qui va la
faire !
Si vous avez entendu parler de Kant, alors
vous savez probablement que, dans l’histoire
de la philosophie, il y un AVANT, et un APRÈS
Kant.
Avant lui, les philosophes élaboraient des
systèmes sans même s’interroger sur leur
capacité à produire des connaissances fiables.
Après Kant, ils ne peuvent plus négliger
le fait que la réalité dont on tire la connaissance
est en partie une construction de l’esprit.
Kant représente donc une rupture majeure
dans l’histoire de la pensée occidentale.
Au point que lorsqu’il faut renommer la
ville où il a vécu, Königsberg, après
la chute de l’URSS, les autorités hésitent
à choisir « Kantograd »
(ce qui signifie « ville de Kant » en russe).
C’est vous dire son prestige.
Et pourtant, à son époque, personne ne parie
sur lui.
Écoutez-moi jusqu’au bout, et vous comprendrez
comment un « touriste » (entre guillemets)
a fini par rivaliser avec Platon et Aristote.
Le père de Kant est artisan sellier, ce qui
signifie qu’il fabrique et répare des équipements
pour les chevaux.
Il appartient à une guilde, l’association
qui définit les règles de son métier.
Et Kant, par sa seule naissance, est membre
de cette guilde.
L’idée — vous l’avez compris — c’est
que Kant est destiné à reprendre l’atelier
de son père.
À l’époque, il n’y a pas de dilemme
d’orientation professionnelle.
Le métier passe très souvent de père en
fils.
Seulement, le pasteur de la famille se rend
compte que le fils de 7 ans est un garçon
bien spécial.
Le petit Kant a un gros potentiel intellectuel.
Et le pasteur ne veut pas gâcher ce potentiel.
Donc il en parle aux parents : il les persuade
d’inscrire leur fils au Collège royal Frédéric,
une des écoles les plus réputées de toute
la Prusse.
Cette école va préparer le petit Kant à
des études ultérieures de théologie, ce
qui est le parcours normal des intellectuels
de l’époque.
Mais comment expliquer que Kant manifeste
un potentiel intellectuel si tôt ?
Son père est artisan — mais pas un des
artisanats les plus prestigieux —
et sa famille appartient à la petite bourgeoisie
— donc c’est pas comme si Kant avait grandi
dans une marmite intellectuelle.
Il a forcément reçu une stimulation intellectuelle
précoce, mais quelle est la source ?
Eh bien c’est probablement sa mère.
En effet, la mère de Kant — comme celle
de Hegel, d’ailleurs — la mère de Kant
est une femme plus éduquée que les femmes
de l’époque.
Dès qu’il faut écrire quelque chose dans
la famille, c’est elle qui s’en occupe.
Elle initie donc son fils au travail intellectuel.
Et elle le fait si bien que vers 7 ans, le
pasteur
— qui est une figure d’autorité morale
et intellectuelle dans la communauté —
lorsque Kant a 7 ans, le pasteur estime que
ce serait dommage d’en faire un artisan,
et que le petit a le potentiel pour une formation
intellectuelle d’élite.
Après, si le rôle de la mère de Kant a
été décisif, l’environnement familial
— plus généralement — est aussi important.
Dans la petite bourgeoisie artisanale de l’époque,
on valorise le travail bien fait, régulier
et rigoureux.
Le petit Kant apprend donc très tôt à faire
des efforts et à s’appliquer.
Et cette discipline lui sera bien utile.
Parce qu’au Collège Frédéric, il n’arrête
pas de bûcher.
Il fait énormément de latin et il se familiarise
avec les classiques.
À 17 ans, il est admis à l’université
de Königsberg comme prévu.
Le talent de Kant se manifeste déjà à l’université.
Les autres étudiants se rendent compte de
sa supériorité intellectuelle, donc il se
forme déjà autour de lui un petit groupe
de quasi-disciples.
Sa culture, sa discipline et sa capacité
de travail les fascinent.
Comme il est très bon et sympa, Kant mentore
certains étudiants.
En gros, il les guide dans leur travail intellectuel.
C’est gratuit…
seulement pour ses amis (ce qui est déjà
sympa).
Pour les autres, c’est payant — donc Kant
monnaye sa compétence intellectuelle assez
tôt.
Sa rémunération est sonnante et trébuchante,
mais certains tutorés le paient en nature,
par exemple avec du café ou du pain.
C’est qu’à l’époque, Kant ne roule
pas sur l’or.
Et du coup, une fois qu’il a fini l’université,
à 24 ans, il est face à un problème très
concret : comment gagner sa croûte ?
Son père vient de mourir et laisse un héritage.
Mais une fois les dettes réglées, il ne
reste pas grand chose.
Et ce pas grand chose doit permettre de prendre
soin des frères et sœurs de Kant.
Donc Kant n’est pas rentier — contrairement
à Descartes ou Schopenhauer.
Il voudrait bien enseigner à l’université,
mais les places sont rares — en plus d’être
mal payées —
et puis il est trop jeune pour prétendre
à une place.
Fils d’un petit artisan, il n’a pas non
plus le réseau pour décrocher un poste dans
l’administration.
Du coup, il n’a qu’une seule option.
Comme tous les pauvres lettrés fraîchement
sortis de l’université — comme ce sera
également le cas de Hegel — Kant n’a
pas le choix :
il doit trouver une place de précepteur (Hofmeister
en allemand).
Il l’est d’abord plusieurs années chez
un prêtre aisé, qui le charge de 3 de ses
5 fils.
Ensuite, encore plusieurs années chez un
grand propriétaire terrien.
Et enfin chez le comte Keyserlingk.
Le fait que Kant soit précepteur aussi longtemps
n’est pas anodin.
Ça signifie qu’il est dans le besoin, que
l’argent est un souci constant pour lui.
Dans la vingtaine et la trentaine, il ne pense
pas à révolutionner la philosophie.
Sa priorité est de vivre de son savoir.
Nous sommes dans la seconde moitié des années
1750.
C’est le début de la trentaine pour Kant.
Cela fait quelques années qu’il a soutenu
sa thèse de philosophie à l’université
de Königsberg (là même où il a étudié).
Il a obtenu son doctorat, ce qui l’autorise
désormais à donner des cours à l’université.
Donc après ses années de préceptorat, sa
carrière universitaire démarre enfin.
Mais ses amis se scandalisent : pourquoi se
met-il à vendre ses livres ?!
Pas lui ! Un intellectuel si brillant !
Il ne peut pas se séparer de ses livres !
Et puis pourquoi est-ce qu’il met toujours
le même manteau ?!
Il est foutu ce manteau ! Il serait bien qu’il
en change.
Ses amis veulent lui en offrir un nouveau.
Kant refuse.
Il veut garder son honneur, mais les premières
années de sa carrière à l’université
de Königsberg sont compliquées financièrement.
Il n’arrive toujours pas à joindre les
deux bouts.
En fait, c’est normal.
Comme il vient d’arriver, il ne touche pas
de salaire.
L’université rémunère uniquement sa quarantaine
de profs permanents — et comme je vous l’ai
dit, ils sont payés au lance-pierre.
Les autres profs, dont Kant, doivent se faire
payer en direct par les élèves.
Et la plupart n’arrivent pas à en vivre,
donc ils doivent prendre un emploi alimentaire
à côté.
Mais Kant, lui, veut gagner sa vie avec ses
cours.
Donc au début, il donne plein de cours collectifs
à l’université — plus d’une vingtaine
par semaine — et il donne en plus des cours
particuliers.
Avec la préparation des cours, il n’arrête
pas.
Et comme il n’y a pas assez de demande pour
une vingtaine d’heures de cours de philo
par semaine, Kant enseigne d’autres matières
!
Il enseigne par exemple la géographie, la
mécanique, l’hydrolique, l’arithmétique,
la géométrie, ou encore la trigonométrie
!
Kant ne devait pas être le meilleur prof
de physique de tous les temps, mais l’objectif
pour lui, c’est surtout de mettre du beurre
dans les épinards.
Et à force de travail, il y parvient.
Il gagne assez pour ne plus avoir à amputer
sa bibliothèque.
De plus en plus d’étudiants sont séduits
par ce prof réputé pour sa supériorité
intellectuelle
(on dit de lui dans l’université qu’il
est un « excellent cerveau »).
Et puis il est original !
Il ne se contente pas de lire un manuel.
Il digresse, raconte des anecdotes.
Il prétend même apprendre aux étudiants
à penser.
Il leur dit : « Vous n'apprendrez pas de
moi la philosophie, mais à philosopher, non
pas simplement des pensées à répéter,
mais à penser.
»
Il est si difficile de gagner sa vie en donnant
des cours à l’université qu’attirer
des étudiants est déjà un succès pour
Kant.
Et la concurrence est telle
— en fait parce qu’il y a trop de profs
par rapport au nombre d’élèves —
la concurrence est telle que le succès de
Kant fait des jaloux.
Au bout d’un moment, les cours de Kant sont
pleins.
Et dans le même temps, d’autres profs voient
leur business péricliter.
Ses concurrents jaloux se mettent à le critiquer
devant leurs élèves.
C’est bon signe !
Kant a été élevé dans un milieu piétiste.
Le piétisme, c’est une nouvelle version
du protestantisme qui se développe en Allemagne
aux XVIIe et XVIIIe siècles et qui insiste
notamment sur la nécessité de mener une
vie morale au quotidien (plutôt que d’adhérer
à des théories précises).
Par exemple, les piétistes interdisent de
jouer aux cartes.
Ils disent carrément que les cartes sont
le « livre de prières du diable », et que
jouer au carte est un chemin qui mène directement
en enfer.
Eh bien ça n’empêche pas Kant de beaucoup
jouer aux cartes à partir de ses études
universitaires.
Il aime tellement jouer aux cartes qu’il
dira même dans une conférence que jouer
aux cartes rend l’homme meilleur en lui
apprenant à maîtriser ses émotions.
Cette anecdote montre que Kant n’est pas
l’homme austère qu’on imagine.
Ses livres sont si abstraits et si rigoureux
qu’on se dit que leur auteur ne connaît
que les livres et la pensée, qu’il n’a
pas de vie sociale.
Eh bien rien n’est plus faux.
Kant est même un homme mondain, c’est-à-dire
qu’il fréquente volontiers l’élite sociale
de Königsberg — il en est même une figure
centrale.
S’il évolue dans ce milieu, c’est surtout
grâce à sa relation avec la dernière famille
dont il a été le précepteur, celle du comte
Keyserlingk.
La comtesse, en particulier, est très éprise
de Kant.
Il est toujours le bienvenu au palace des
Keyserlingk, il peut y dîner n’importe
quand
— mais en fait, Kant est invité par la
plupart des familles de l’élite locale.
Dans sa trentaine, Kant est tellement mondain
qu’il est rarement chez lui.
Il passe la plupart des après-midi à jouer
aux cartes.
Ensuite il est invité à dîner quelque part.
Et il passe la soirée à discuter ou à jouer
aux cartes, si bien qu’il rentre souvent
chez lui après minuit.
Les rares fois où il est invité nulle part,
il mange au restaurant.
Si Kant est un habitué des cercles mondains,
c’est parce qu’il est très agréable.
Les gens — en particulier les femmes — se
sentent bien dans sa compagnie.
Non seulement il est très intéressant — grâce
à sa vaste culture — mais il est très
sympathique.
Et Kant ne se laisse pas happer par les mondanités.
Il pense que sa vie sociale très active est
bénéfique.
À ses amis qui passent beaucoup de temps
dans les livres, il dit qu’on ne s’éduque
véritablement que par la fréquentation de
ses semblables.
Une autre raison de la popularité de Kant
dans les mondanités, c’est son élégance.
Les gens qui le fréquentent disent qu’il
est très bel homme :
le corps svelte, les cheveux blonds, une belle
peau qui donne une impression de fraîcheur,
des yeux dont même les hommes remarquent
la beauté.
En plus, Kant s’habille avec des vêtements
élégants et finement décorés.
Bref, on est loin de la caricature du philosophe
universitaire.
D’après Kant, un homme atteint la maturité
à 40 ans.
Il peut être intelligent bien plus tôt (par
exemple dans sa vingtaine) —
mais c’est seulement à 40 ans qu’il a
acquis assez d’expérience, qu’il a connu
une diversité de situations suffisante pour
enfin comprendre l’existence et le monde
dans leur complexité.
La personnalité atteint sa forme finale à
40 ans.
Bon, c’est peut-être vrai pour beaucoup
de gens.
Mais ça révèle surtout que la quarantaine
est un tournant pour Kant lui-même.
Il connaît une crise existentielle.
Et à l’issue de cette crise, le beau professeur
mondain devient le grand penseur.
Il y a plusieurs raisons à cette mutation.
Tout d’abord, l’environnement social de
Kant change.
Son meilleur ami de l’époque meurt.
Les liens avec d’autres amis se distendent.
Et Kant se fait de nouveaux amis.
Ensuite, il a l’impression qu’il est en
train de gâcher son potentiel.
Il a beaucoup d’idées sur beaucoup de sujets
— mais il ne peut pas se faire un nom en
philosophie en passant son temps dans les
dîners mondains et à jouer aux cartes.
Alors que, dans sa vingtaine, on disait de
lui qu’il était un « excellent cerveau
», dans sa quarantaine, on ne le voit plus
que comme un homme du monde.
Mais la quarantaine marque pour Kant une nouvelle
étape dans sa vie.
Jusqu’à 40 ans, l’esprit accumule les
matériaux intellectuels ; ingère et digère.
À partir de 40 ans, l’esprit est mûr pour
créer.
La quarantaine est donc une renaissance pour
Kant.
Mais cette renaissance se produit-elle d’elle-même
?
Pas vraiment.
Pardon pour l’interruption, mais j’ai
une question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale, ce
n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas qu’un seul
secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets, mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT leur
culture générale, parce que leur rapport
au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur sur
n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour faire
preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes, donc
faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
Kant et un de ses nouveaux amis prévoient
de faire une sortie en calèche à la campagne
le lendemain à 8h du matin.
Le jour suivant, son ami est là à l’attendre
à 7h45.
À 8h, Kant n’est toujours pas là.
Que fait son ami ? Il part dans la calèche
?!
Et qui la calèche rencontre-t-elle sur le
chemin ? Kant !
Il fait signe à la calèche de s’arrêter.
Ses mouvements sont si vigoureux que le cocher
et le passager le voient forcément.
Mais voilà, son ami dit au cocher de ne pas
s’arrêter.
Ça c’est un ami ?!
Oui, et pas n’importe lequel.
Joseph Green est l’homme à l’origine
de la renaissance de Kant.
Sans cet ami, le professeur ne serait pas
devenu le grand penseur.
Kant et Joseph Green se lient pile quand le
philosophe a 40 ans.
Qu’a-t-il de si spécial, ce nouvel ami
?
Eh bien c’est un homme d’une incroyable
discipline.
La régularité — c’est-à-dire le fait
de répéter les mêmes actions —
et la ponctualité — c’est-à-dire le
fait de maîtriser son temps avec exactitude
—
la régularité et la ponctualité sont la
religion du nouvel ami de Kant.
Sa discipline est si sévère qu’il est
devenu un personnage de comédie.
Comme le dit Bergson, le rire est « du mécanique
plaqué sur du vivant ».
Eh bien Joseph Green est comme un robot programmé.
Alors qu’un individu normal — et sain,
à mon avis — s’arrêterait pour accueillir
son ami dans la calèche, Green, lui, est
incapable de s’adapter à un imprévu par
amitié.
Dans cette scène, sa discipline extrême
est risible.
Mais elle lui donne un avantage dans les affaires.
En effet, Joseph Green n’est pas un universitaire,
mais un marchand anglais — le meilleur marchand
anglais de Königsberg.
Et pourtant, les affaires ne sont pas sa passion.
Sa passion, ce sont les livres — d’où
son affinité avec Kant.
Joseph Green vit comme un ermite érudit.
Il passe la plupart de son temps à se cultiver
chez lui, et il organise son existence selon
des règles ultra-strictes.
Kant et lui deviennent inséparables.
Ils sont si ponctuels que les voisins de Green
règlent leur horloge quand Kant sort de la
maison de son ami.
Ce n’est donc pas Kant, le professeur mondain,
qui influence son ami.
C’est Green, l’ermite érudit psychorigide,
qui déteint sur Kant.
Et pas qu’un peu :
Kant devient lui aussi obsédé par les règles,
plus précisément par ce qu’il appelle
les maximes
(c’est-à-dire des règles de conduite,
des principes d’action).
Et c’est cette image de lui que gardera
la postérité.
Donc c’est Joseph Green, le marchand anglais,
qui a fait le Kant que nous connaissons.
C’est son exemple, son influence qui ont
tiré Kant des mondanités et qui l’ont
réaligné avec son ambition intellectuelle.
Kant dira même que Green lui a donné son
avis sur chaque phrase de la Critique de la
raison pure, le chef-d’œuvre qui le fera
entrer dans l’histoire de la pensée.
Il suffit parfois d’une rencontre pour rencontrer
son destin.
Dans la quarantaine, Kant rencontre une aristocrate
de Westphalie.
Cette femme ne s’est pas rendue seule à
Königsberg : elle est accompagnée par une
belle jeune femme à laquelle Kant est sensible.
Ils se voient à de multiples reprises et
se plaisent l’un l’autre.
Le temps passe, et Kant se met à penser qu’elle
pourrait bien être plus qu’une amie.
Un jour, il se sent enfin prêt à faire une
offre de mariage.
Seulement voilà, ce jour-même, la jeune
femme est en train de passer la frontière
: elle rentre chez elle.
C’est donc raté.
Mais ce n’est pas la première fois que
Kant rate sa chance.
Parce qu’à l’égard du mariage, il est
indécis.
Pourtant, il plaît aux femmes.
Il est un bel homme sympathique ; il est professeur
à l’université ;
et il est apprécié au sein de l’élite
sociale de Königsberg, où les occasions
de mariage ne manquent pas.
S’il avait VRAIMENT voulu se marier, il
aurait certainement réussi.
Mais non.
Pourquoi Kant ne se marie-t-il pas ?
Au départ — disons jusqu’à la trentaine
— c’est à cause de l’argent.
Kant calcule qu’il ne gagne pas assez pour
soutenir financièrement une famille.
Mais à l’époque, c’est le sort de beaucoup
d’universitaires.
Les rares à franchir le pas sont ceux qui
dénichent de riches veuves.
Plus le temps avance, plus Kant devient sceptique
à l’égard du mariage lui-même.
Au milieu de la quarantaine, il voit ce qui
est arrivé à certains de ses amis, et il
ne veut pas connaître le même sort.
Il ne veut pas se faire dominer par une jeune
femme capricieuse.
Et puis enfin, il y a aussi l’influence
de son nouveau meilleur ami, le psychorigide
Joseph Green, qui est évidemment un célibataire.
Dès lors, Kant considère que se marier n’est
même plus une option.
Il devient même allergique à cette idée.
S’il anticipe qu’on va lui en parler lors
d’un dîner, il préfère ne pas se rendre
à ce dîner.
Donc Kant restera célibataire jusqu’au
bout.
Sa situation financière s’améliorera avec
le temps.
Mais il restera dans la misère sentimentale
et sexuelle.
Nous sommes au début des années 1780 : Kant
a la soixantaine.
Cela fait seulement une dizaine d’années
qu’il a été nommé prof titulaire, et
là, il commence à craindre de perdre son
poste.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’il devient célèbre en Allemagne…
pour son athéisme !
Son chef-d’œuvre, la Critique de la raison
pure, est sortie il y a quelques années,
et ce livre commence seulement à rencontrer
le succès espéré.
Mais le problème, c’est que c’est un
succès nourri par la controverse.
En fait, ce n’est pas possible autrement,
parce que les gens ne comprennent pas la Critique
de la raison pure — c’est bien trop compliqué.
Si ce livre gagne en notoriété, c’est
parce qu’on dit qu’il contient des idées
subversives.
Les pamphlets se multiplient.
On accuse Kant de prêcher l’immoralité.
S’il se laisse faire, il va avoir des problèmes.
Comment réagit-il ?
À une attaque collective, il faut une réponse
collective.
Kant organise la riposte avec ses partisans.
Il les autorise, puis les incite à vulgariser
et à défendre son système.
Et avec le temps, leur participation n’est
plus vraiment…
comment dire…
libre.
La défense du kantisme prend une dimension
quasi mafieuse.
J’exagère un peu, mais Kant se comporte
presque en chef de gang philosophique.
Il n’accepte plus qu’on le contredise
et il est obsédé par son territoire intellectuel.
Il se rend compte que lorsque ses partisans
prennent la plume pour défendre la Critique
de la raison pure, eh bien ça marche.
Ses idées gagnent du terrain dans l’opinion.
Du coup, Kant encourage ses disciples et ses
amis à le faire.
Puis les encouragements deviennent des coups
de pression.
Les amis dégoûtés par cette méthode s’éloignent
de Kant.
Mais grâce à son nouveau prestige philosophique,
il conserve des disciples qui acceptent d’aller
au combat pour lui.
Parfois, le missionné est réticent : il
a d’autres choses à faire ;
et puis, il en a déjà fait assez pour mériter
l’attention et la considération du maître.
Que fait Kant ? Il force son disciple à prendre
la plume.
Cette anecdote montre que la qualité des
idées ne suffit probablement pas à les imposer
dans l’esprit des hommes.
Comme avec une religion, il faut des disciples
fidèles qui prêchent la bonne parole et
qui la défendent agressivement contre les
idées concurrentes.
À 70 ans, Kant reçoit une réprimande officielle
du roi de Prusse.
Il ne doit plus discréditer la religion dans
ses écrits.
« Sans effort de votre part, vous devez vous
attendre à des mesures désagréables pour
votre obstination continue.
»
Ces menaces sont sérieuses : Kant pourrait
être mis à la retraite et privé de revenus,
ou même forcé à l’exil
— lui qui a passé toute sa vie à Königsberg,
il n’a pas envie d’en partir à 70 ans.
Il ne se met pas en mode « lèche-bottes
» pour autant.
En particulier, il n’a pas peur de perdre
sa pension.
Il est financièrement indépendant parce
qu’il a investi ses revenus intelligemment.
Il n’est pas riche, mais il est dans l’aisance
financière — l’argent n’est plus un
souci pour lui.
C’est donc sans génuflexions que Kant promet
de ne plus écrire sur les questions religieuses.
Cette anecdote illustre l’irréligion de
Kant.
C’est-à-dire que non seulement il n’a
pas de conviction religieuse, mais il n’hésite
pas à s’écarter de la doctrine religieuse
officielle dans ses discours.
Il n'est pas seulement vu comme athée à
cause de mauvaises interprétations de ses
livres.
Bien au contraire : il prend des précautions
à l’écrit, pas dans sa vie personnelle.
Les gens qui le fréquentent l’entendent
souvent se moquer de la prière et d’autres
pratiques religieuses.
Il déteste la religion organisée.
Ses amis ont également compris qu’il ne
croit pas en Dieu.
Pourtant, ses parents l’avaient éduqué
dans la religion.
Mais la seule chose qui est restée du piétisme
de sa famille, c’est sa discipline personnelle.
En fait, Kant est un philosophe des Lumières.
Il n’attaque pas la religion frontalement
comme Voltaire, mais il contribue à promouvoir
l’idéal des Lumières
— essentiellement la foi en le pouvoir de
la raison —
il contribue à promouvoir cet idéal à Königsberg.
À partir de la cinquantaine, Kant a de gros
problèmes de digestion.
Il ne cherche pas à les dissimuler
— au contraire, il en parle à ses invités,
et même dans des soirées mondaines, ce qui
provoque des éclats de rire.
Pourquoi est-ce que les gens rient ?
Parce que Kant est hypocondriaque.
Donc la manière dont il décrit ses symptômes
trahit une obsession qui est comique.
Mais cette obsession n’est pas sortie de
nulle part.
Kant a toujours eu une santé fragile.
Il a un corps petit (1m57) et frêle.
Il a du mal à respirer, à cause de quoi
il ne peut pas supporter de grands efforts
physiques.
Il a aussi pas mal d’allergies.
Par exemple, un journal tout fraîchement
imprimé le fait éternuer.
Kant est conscient de sa fragilité, donc
il vit avec prudence.
Il ne fait pas d’excès.
À partir de la cinquantaine, il limite ses
problèmes digestifs en suivant un régime
strict.
Ses amis disent qu’il va écrire une Critique
de la cuisine.
Kant n’a jamais été en parfaite santé
dans sa vie — mais grâce à sa prudence,
il n’a jamais de gros soucis.
Seulement, il est obsédé par ses soucis
de santé.
Il en est conscient, et il est conscient de
l’effet psychologique délétère de son
obsession.
Mais l’hypocondrie est une mode à la fin
du XVIIIe siècle.
Elle est particulièrement en vogue parmi
les intellectuels, qui l’associent à la
mélancolie.
Il n’est donc pas étonnant que Kant et
plusieurs de ses amis se disent hypocondriaques.
Son seul véritable gros problème de santé,
il n’en aura pas conscience : il perd la
tête à la fin de sa vie.
Dans sa dernière décennie, ses facultés
mentales déclinent et il devient insomniaque.
Déjà que ses livres étaient difficiles
à comprendre, mais ses derniers textes contiennent
carrément des incohérences.
Il invente des théories farfelues.
Il se fait arnaquer par un domestique parce
qu’il ne reconnaît plus les pièces et
les billets.
C’est tragique : l’« excellent cerveau
» de l’université de Königsberg, un des
plus grands penseurs de l’Occident, est
vaincu par la maladie d’Alzheimer.
Si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre.
Ce travail est vraiment formidable et passionnant.
»
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable.
J'étais un peu dubitatif étant donné le
prix initial mais je ne regrette pas, c'est
un vrai travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui ai une mémoire essentiellement auditive.
Le choix des thèmes et des chapitres est
pertinent et je trouve que tu as trouvé la
dose d'approfondissement parfaite ; à la
fois précis mais sans fioritures ! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme.
Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous bénéficiez
d'une garantie résultats : une fois que vous
aurez terminé le programme, je vous rembourserai
intégralement si vous estimez que vous n’avez
pas acquis une solide culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
Dans tous les cas, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu.
Je suis Romain, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.